ce convoi russe de chars d'assaut était
à 30 km de la capitale
quand les ukrainiens ont attaqué
ces images ont été publiées par l'armée
ukrainienne qui a bien l'intention de
prendre les grands moyens pour défendre
kiev les soldats qui ont préparé
l'embuscade sont fiers des résultats
nous avons détruit deux chars dit il est
tué près de 30 soldats russes dont le
commandant du convoi
l'armée russe fait aussi sa propagande
en publiant cette vidéo censée montrer
sa progression sur le terrain mais dans
les faits au sol ils trouvent de poutine
kittin karkhiv que moi je couds pensait
prendre rapidement n'est toujours pas
tombée
je ne doute pas que nous allons
atteindre nos objectifs dit vladimir
poutine dans la rue s'il nie avoir
bombardé à mario paul un hôpital
pédiatrique une maternité
les skyhawks havrais anyama l'eau pour
l'avenir au port neuf
le ministère russe de la défense accuse
même des nationalistes ukrainiens
d'avoir orchestré une mise en scène pour
soulever la colère de l'opinion publique
internationale
toutes les capitales occidentales ont
sévèrement condamné l'attaqué qui a fait
trois morts et 17 blessés la france
condamne avec la plus grande fermeté ce
qui est un acte de guerre indigné un
moral dans stalker
dit
le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères était en turquie pour tenter
de négocier un cessez-le-feu avec son
vis-à-vis ukrainien sans succès oui de
nantes
il n'y a pas eu de progrès dit le
ministre qui répète que l'ukraine ne va
pas capituler sergueï lavrorv affirme
lui que la russie n'a pas l'intention
d'attaquer d'autres pays et il lance cet
avertissement cirque pendant
roger les pays dit il qui arment
l'ukraine se devra en porter la
responsabilité de leur âge ici sophie
langlois radio canada montréal